looking back at your period of
non-monogamy now as a happily married
man woman of your dreams
does that reframe that sort of
experience do you have a different sort
of view of non-monogamy generally now
was it just part of a journey where's
your head space out with that
it's uh it was definitely part of a
journey it's definitely part of like a
deep learning practice i mean we all
have jealousy to a certain extent
you know it's just inherent and if you
think you're not jealous i dare you to
get into a non-monogamous relationship
where your sweetheart is getting [ __ ]
by somebody else in your home alone and
just imagining what's happening like if
you can do that like
[ __ ] get an ashram somewhere like i
don't i don't know i don't know what it
takes to be able to handle that but
you know so you really confront the
dragon you confront the dragon of your
own jealousy like the the thought of me
being jealous in my current relationship
now with mylana is absolutely
preposterous because i've lived in the
worst case scenario
you know like i've lived the i've lived
the absolute nightmare
of of you know jealousy
so many times that i'm liberated from
that it's just not in the it's not in
the spectrum of possibility of what i
would actually worry about and that's
the that's one of the beautiful things
that you'll get from it
and that's what happens when you go head
first into your deepest fears or your
deepest challenges it's like the
ayahuasca of jealousy right you're
[ __ ] you're in it so that's beautiful
it's also beautiful that i mean i got to
experience so many amazing people and
actually
i was only able to meet my wife and
become friends because i had the freedom
of a non-monogamous container like if i
wanted to go out on a friend date or
whatever with vilana like there was
never any question because i had
multiple other girlfriends so it's not
like there was an issue you know like i
was really free
so
i think it's it's a great path to
overcome jealousy it's also a great path
if you're not quite sure i loved whitney
a lot but it something wasn't just quite
right you know she's amazing whitney's
[ __ ] incredible
but it wasn't quite right for either of
us
and we've both actually subsequently
after since splitting you know we're
still friends but both of us have really
come into our own in a beautiful way
she's a country singer now you know and
she's like using her voice and she's
recording songs and songs are amazing
and i've always always wanted to sing
but in our relationship it just that
never emerged like there was ways in
which we weren't clicking for each
other's future
so the fact that we chose non-monogamy
was perfect because we were both free to
explore different people and learn
different things and it was it was
beautiful i got to meet some amazing
amazing humans you know stephanie and
savannah and maya and so many like
awesome people that i'm just so grateful
that i got a chance to experience
so that you know there was those are the
benefits
of it
we also made a lot of mistakes
one of the things that non-monogamy
requires is
perfect blisteringly honest
communication
like any little way in which you're
withholding the truth
becomes
explodes into a nightmare so it's also
great for practicing your honesty
like you really have to if you have
feelings for somebody or you think
something you feel something you have to
express it because the only safe place
you have is the truth and as soon as the
truth gets a little twisted
everything is in question and nothing
makes sense and you're just lost
so it's it's kind of a forging process
can i see it as
a
viable long-term solution
[Music]
i can but it requires
the very best it requires a group of
people who are out there operating at
their very best in in heart and mind and
spirit and i think it can be a really
beautiful sacred non-monogamous union
uh i was never i was never quite good
enough to be honest i was never able to
really get there and i tried i tried
hard eight years you know i gave it
everything i got i was not the type of
person that was capable of holding that
indefinitely
i never transcended my jealousy i never
got to the place of compersion which is
getting pleasure from someone else's
pleasure sustainably
you know like
if whitney's having a
orgasmic blissful experience with uh
with another lover
i was never like oh babe
i'm so happy for your orgasmic blissful
experience
oh are those
hand print bruises on your ass it must
have been passionate
passionate when he was spanking you that
hard i i'd love that you were that into
it with him no i was never like that i
wanted to vomit you know i just i
couldn't do it you know so but that
doesn't mean that it's not possible to
do
you know it doesn't mean that
my failures mean that the the whole
construct is flawed because i think the
construct is beautiful but for me
it was just too hard
i think there's a definitely a
difference in my mind between using it
as a tool
to prepare yourself for a potential
future relationship
and attaching your colours to the mass
pole and saying right this is me for the
remainder of time
in
my experience
spending a lot of time around a lot of
people
you need to be an incredibly unique
individual for that to be the right path
for you to go down long term i mean even
for you to go down it for two weeks you
need to be a pretty unique individual um
but for you to be able to look back
after
potentially an entire lifetime of
non-monogamy and say yes
that was the right choice i think that
you have to be
very very a significant outlier and i
also think that there's probably far
fewer people than actually think it and
what's reassuring to hear what's kind of
nice to hear from yourself is that look
like this is something that you can
perhaps consider or try or look at
but it's not
it's not for life you're not married to
the non-monogamy for life you know if
you if you want to bail out if you want
to make an exit plan at some point
you can do that
and
yeah one thing that i had in my mind is
it
so you've mentioned about the fact that
the jealousy was something one of the
sort of key emotions that you struggled
with and that
this was kind of like exposure therapy
for jealousy turned up to a million
is there any part of you
that
has echoes of that because that can be
so traumatic to the point where
it starts to embed a habit it starts to
embed a routine that the jealousy
actually starts to rear its head and
it's got all of this
foundation and this power and this
velocity behind it because look at all
of the things that you've done in the
past
do you ever notice that do you ever feel
that
you know the the thing about it is
the jealousy i think jealousy becomes
really toxic when it's imagined
right like imagined jealousy
you you're just thinking and you're
you're waiting for this
dishonest way in which someone is
betraying you is that because you didn't
know do you think that's because of the
shame or the guilt around the fact that
you know that it's it's this part of it
that's not true and that there's almost
a little bit of it that's making it your
fault if the jealousy doesn't actually
exist if there's no real reason for it
to be there the shame because it's you
that's causing it
yeah i think that i think that's a
factor i also think that that's like
that's the difference between
polyamory and just a regular
relationship where you're jealous a lot
of times in a regular relationship where
you're jealous you're just creating all
kinds of fantasies of
things that are not real and so you
pattern this fantastical creation of
these jealous circumstances
you know this is what you see all the
time were you looking at that girl where
uh do you have what what what are you
what are you doing with that trainer you
know like do you like him you're like
blah blah like no he's just my friend
like blah blah blah because you're
creating all these fantasies
the the beauty of what i experienced was
it was all real
like she was really having
blissful orgasmic experiences with men
for real and would tell me about it as
you know because we're honest and then
she was really falling in love with her
boyfriend
ricky and really like all of these
things were really happening
so
while it was hard it was honest and i
think
anything that's hard and honest is
productive and not traumatic
it's just productive right it's just
it's kind of like going into a sweat
lodge like i don't know if you've ever
done like a really intense temescal or
sweat lodge nope
pitch dark you know you're in there
three hours
no water it's just prayers and heat and
they're pouring water on these steaming
rocks and
you feel at certain points if it's a
hard lodge like i don't know how i'm
going to survive this like i don't know
this is so hot and i'm so thirsty and
i'm and i'm like just overwhelmed with
this and if you're with a real master
they know where the edge is and they
never obviously push it and of course
you could wave the white flag i'm not
and they always make allowances for that
because it can be dangerous
but ultimately that's a super
challenging experience but you never
leave that traumatic you leave that
exhilarated because it's honest you
chose it you know what it is and you
endure it
and you come out and you're you're like
rebirth from the fire
and that's kind of the way that it is
with polyamory it's like it's real it's
like a sweat lodge like you know you
know when your partner is with that
other person you know and you know
what's how you know what's happening and
what's happening is worse than you hope
but not as bad as you fear right always
always that's like the universal rule
it's worse than you hope but not as bad
as you fear but if that's where it's
gonna that's what's happening
and and so it's
it's intense but it's not traumatic
what's traumatic is is like discovering
an adultery
you know like my my wife my wife had a
lot of trauma
not she was not she was monogamous but
on two of her birthdays she found out
that her boyfriend had impregnated
another woman that he was seeing on the
side
the same boyfriend
two different ones two different
boyfriends both on a birthday
both on her birthday
what are the [ __ ] chances of that
that's
right yeah happy birthday i'm not going
to be here because i'm getting an
abortion with this other girl that you
didn't know i was seeing [ __ ] you know
like that's that's where the trauma
comes from like that's what imprints
like deep trauma because lack whereas if
it's
yeah it's the lack of truth whereas the
other thing is just
it's just a it's just a really difficult
initiation and that's that's kind of how
i feel so i actually look back at that
as hard as it was
i look back at that and there's like a
sense of almost a sense of pride
like yeah i [ __ ] did that you know i
did that i tossed and turned and i
wrestled in my bed and i puked and i
cried and i prayed to god and i made it
through
you know and like i did it
[ __ ] yeah you know it's like it's like
running an ultra marathon you know it's
hell but
i've never run one but i can imagine i
don't like running like two miles let
alone [ __ ] a hundred
but
it's the same thing like it breaks you
down but you you're proud you're proud
that you went through it because you
knew what you were doing and you just
you did it
at the time was it ever in your head
that
you were doing something to become ready
for this sort of woman that you wanted
to spend the rest of your life with
no because i didn't think the woman that
i wanted to spend the rest of my life
with existed
i thought maybe it was vilana but she
never
she never really gave me any
any indication that she was interested
in that type of relationship until until
she did
i thought like maybe but i didn't know
her that well
intimately you know like we i knew her
as a friend but there was still a lot of
boundaries you know that she always had
she was very loyal to the people she was
seeing and
so i thought like look
here's my options either i compromise
with one person
or i just stay non-monogamous continue
to work on my jealousy get to be with a
bunch of different beautiful people and
i get to experience life and my
my
sacred union is with the great beloved
like rumi talks about like like all of
creation woman with a capital w embodied
in many different women
i really believe that was my future and
actually
interestingly i i think i finally got to
the place like right before vilana and i
got together i was like
i think i did it i'm [ __ ] happy
like i did it i'm happy you know and
like i didn't mind that whitney was you
know in love and seeing seeing her guy
still i i really didn't bother me that
much and she would go on dates and we'd
laugh about it and i had a bunch of
different dates that i was going on and
i was like
i think i made it i think i [ __ ] made
it
and then vilana came in and i was like
oh my god
this is the this is the path for me so
it took me by surprise
i just didn't want to ever compromise
you know i never wanted to compromise
and vilana was the the absolute there
are no compromises it's like i had a
bingo card with 100 different squares
and the balls kept coming out and i hit
every single one
100 out of 100 and i'm like whoa i
didn't think that was possible
but it was it was for me and i don't
know if it is possible for everybody
the reason that i say it is i've been
thinking a lot recently talking to some
friends about sort of becoming the man
that you want your future wife
to fall in love with you know creating
the life that you want to bring your
children into the world for being in the
place doing the work with the people
with the connections with the skill set
with the mindset with the balance with
the understanding of yourself and so on
and so on
and
it seems to me that
as
people get married or make commitments
to their life partners later and later
this is a luxury that we now have
and this is one that i don't really hear
very many people talking about
the opportunity to not only treat
your 20s and you know whatever period up
until you finally find the person you
want to be with
as time to explore and learn about you
and work out who you are but also to
become the person that you want that
family to be built upon especially as a
man
right you know sort of
load it up on my back like i'll continue
carrying like put more on put more
weight on put more weight on it's like
well if you haven't spent sufficient
time being able to build up your
tolerance you're not going to be able to
bear a very heavy load
and yeah i
wonder
i think there's something there i think
there's something there
for men
in a crisis of masculinity age
to think okay
maybe you're not getting married at 19
to the daughter of the daughter of next
door's farmer like anymore maybe that's
not happening
but
if you are a romantic if you do want to
lead a life in service of a family if
you know that you want to be a father if
you know that you want to be the
head of a household a leader somebody
that other people can look up to part of
your local community to have impact both
locally
familiarly
familiarily whatever family and
in terms of your work and your
contributions there
if you want to do that you can spend
your time preparing for that
you can spend time becoming that sort of
person being able to bear the load that
you know eventually one day you're going
to have to carry
i don't really hear i haven't really
heard much about that and it seems to me
although it wasn't done it definitely
wasn't planned that way
uh in that as you've just said like just
as you thought you got it all sorted out
someone came in and like sideswiped you
in an articulated lorry and completely
[ __ ] it all up again right going in a
different direction now um yeah
but it certainly seems to me sort of
reflecting on the non-monogamy period it
looks like
[ __ ] prep school prep school for
marriage yeah
yeah
absolutely
i mean i i think we need to do we have a
very comfortable life
we need to do hard [ __ ]
we need if we want to be the man that
can really hold as an anchor and as a
pillar
in our in our family we need to do hard
[ __ ]
polyamory is is one of the hard things
and people don't really get it but like
to get them to get the benefit of
polyamory like there's the man's fantasy
right like oh you get to be with a bunch
of girls i'm like yeah i do
but i also all of these girls that i
have deep
love and feelings for they get to be
with whoever the [ __ ] they want and i
don't get to say no
you know like
like that's the
that's the work
that's where you're really in it
and i think there that's a hard thing
and that that hard thing forges you like
this is the iron that sharpens iron this
is the pressure in the heat that makes
diamonds
and it's just one of the ways you know i
think the plant medicine path is another
way there's
so many other ways that you can get you
know athletics doing hard things for
your body even a consistent cold plunge
practice talk about just something daily
that you can do where you look at that
cold plunge and you don't go like yeah
but you walk in like a [ __ ] king
that's what charles eisenstein says you
say you look at that cold plunge and you
walk in like a king
you know none of this like oh it's cold
let me huh just know you walk in and you
step in like a king and you drop down
and you submerge and you start your
breathing you do it like these things
these things are all forging practices
and they make us who we are so that
we're able to walk into those challenges
and those difficulties because they're
all going to come
you know whether it's you're in a
business and everything goes into chaos
some crazy [ __ ] happens and
you know you have to [ __ ] deal with
deal with
the surprise element
you